Couple of years ago, I started writing
on the internet and it changed my life.
Here's the story that nobody's asked
for, but I've never told it.
About four or five years ago, I was
going through what I would call my first
midlife crisis where I was nearing my
30s and I was at a job that I didn't
know if I wanted to do for the next
decade of my life. And I just started
[music] questioning everything. I was
doing a lot of client work. I was
helping businesses. I was doing web
design, graphic design, all this stuff,
but for other people. Basically, I'd
spent my entire 20s like climbing
corporate ladders and growing
organizations, but I hadn't built
anything for my own. And I was really
starting to feel that. You get to the
end of your 20s and you're like, "Oh my
god, what is what is mine that I haven't
given to a client? What is mine that I
haven't given to my company? What can I
look back and say this was for me?" And
honestly, I I didn't have anything. I I
had all kinds of stuff that I built for
other people. I'd made great money doing
it, but nothing that I can say was
inherently mine. And then about 28 29
years old, I uh I bought this book from
from Nicholas Kohl's called The Art and
Business [music] of Online Writing. A
friend recommended it to me because he
thought I was a good writer, but I
didn't consider myself a writer. I liked
writing blogs and and and [music] tweets
and things like that every now and then,
but every time I thought of a writer, I
thought of some broke artist who made no
money, who smoked a cigarette and drank
espresso in a cafe and was constantly
thinking of novels and all this stupid
imagery that you get with it, which
honestly sounds so badass. But anyh who,
I read this book and uh and I thought it
was so good. I was like, "Oh my gosh,
you can make [music] money writing on
the internet." and like not having
clients [music]
and and not working for a a big
organiza. It was just a big mindblow to
me, which I know sounds kind of dumb
looking back, but but hilarious enough.
I read this book and I started writing
on Twitter immediately. And I think the
thing that I really liked about writing
on Twitter [music] was I could post a
tweet or I could post a thread without
anybody's permission. Like I didn't have
to take it to my boss, to my colleague.
I didn't have [music] to ask a client,
do you like this? And they're like, we
have a million revisions. And I'm like,
"Oh my god." And it it was just so
freeing to be able to write on the
internet. And so I think that was the
first unlock that changed [music] my
life was permissionless writing,
permissionless creativity. That started
to change my mind, my mindset, and and
how I approached business [music]
entirely. And from writing on Twitter, I
met a lot of great [music] people. I met
friends like Eddie Quan and Daniel Thros
and Chris Orzikowski and Ben said, all
these copywriters, all these great
people. Uh, I met Dino, Art of Purpose,
Jordan Parker, Kieran Drew, like all
these cool guys that I that I ended up
following, reading their stuff, buying
their courses, learning about more
writing. And so that was the second
unlock of how writing online changed my
life was that I started meeting all of
these incredible people, people that had
bigger aspirations than anybody else I
had worked with. I mean, everybody else
that I was knowing [music] just wanted
to again climb the corporate ladder and
pay their bills and which is totally
fine. Like I'm not knocking that. But
then when you meet people who are like
building these mega empires by writing
[music] words and blogs and newsletters,
I'm like, how is this possible? And you
meet people launching companies and
softwares and all this stuff. And I'm
saying these these people are ambitious.
These people are doing really cool
things. And you can just literally
connect with anyone. That led me down
the rabbit hole from just writing online
to copywriting. Cuz my background all of
my 20s, I did marketing. I did social
media marketing, graphic design, web
design, things like that. [music] But
then I had spent all this time learning
how to write the art and craft of
writing. I fell in love with writing.
And then when I found copywriting, those
two worlds like merged. I was like, it's
marketing, but it's writing. You write,
but it sells stuff. This is amazing. My
mind was just absolutely [music]
blown. And I realized I was 50 years
behind on copywriting. And so from
there, I went down the rabbit hole. Joe
Sugarman, Ben Settle, Daniel Thros,
Chris Orzowski, Gary Benfena, John
Carlton. I mean, I have like thousands
of dollars worth of courses and [music]
copywriting books. I read every book
twice. There was not a day that went by
that I didn't spend four or five hours a
day either writing or thinking about
writing. That led to me starting my own
newsletter, which led to me writing
daily emails, [music]
which led to me publishing my first
book, which launched as a number one
bestseller. It's back here somewhere. I
don't know where it is. [music] Which
then led to me launching a YouTube
channel, my website, launching my own
products and email list, which actually
bought me back all the time and money
from client work. I don't do client work
anymore at all because I have my own
website, my own newsletter. I make my
own [music] products. I've done multiple
five figure launches collaborating with
some of the best copywriters in the
world. And all of that started because
[music] I bought a book and I started
tweeting. and that writing online,
showing up consistently, it was hard. It
was brutal. I was a really bad writer.
And I'd spent thousands of hours
thinking about how to write better, how
to find my niche, and all that stuff.
But now, now, just a short time, you
know, four or five years later, I'm
coming here and I and I work from home
in my own office and I launch my own
products and I write my own emails and
nobody tells me what I can write or not
write. And I have more freedom and
autonomy than I ever thought I would in
life. And so the reason I share this is
because I think you can do the same
thing. I wanted to encourage you. I want
to inspire you. If you have a Wi-Fi
connection and a heart [music] to write,
then copywriting can change your life.
And if you don't know where to start, I
have a ton of YouTube videos. I also
have a free copywriting guide down
[music] below. Copywriting catalyst. 63
cash cow copywriting secrets that I've
learned while studying [music] it
intensely over the last four or five
years. It's absolutely free for you. You
can also join my email list. I write
every day. Maybe that's some
encouragement, [music] some inspiration
for you to show up every day. I give you
tips on writing copywriting to help you
build a freedom based, autonomy,
leveragebased business where you're not
working for clients and trying to climb
the corporate ladder, but you're
actually trying to buy freedom,
autonomy, and just the [music] joy of
life for yourself. If that sounds good,
click the links down below. Can't wait
to chat with you every day. Also, before
you go, hey, leave a comment down below.
Introduce yourself. Let's start a
conversation. Meeting people on the
internet is one of the coolest things in
the world. So, I'd [music] love to meet
you. Uh, if you found this video
helpful, if you found my other videos
helpful, make sure to like the video,
subscribe, share it with a friend, and
uh, and I'll catch you on the next one.
Yeah, this really good book. What else?
All the Ben Settle stuff, obviously.
[music] Anything by Ryan Holiday.
Thousands of book. I need more
bookshelves. Fiction. Oh my gosh. Right
now, [music] I'm reading Red Rising,
Golden Sun, Morning Star, bro. So good.
And you just read, write a ton, you'll
be happier in